USMLE step oh my goodness med students
sort of med students here all right
we're going to go ahead and get started
okay okay thank you for coming to the
informatics discovery lab lecture here
at the department of medical informatics
and clinical epidemiology as you know we
stream these live and so if you're
listening live you can send it to 82 at
ohsu informatics and someone will be
monitoring it and we can take your
questions there and I have to remind you
that as well since we are doing this
live that if you will hold down little
buttons on little speakers near your
seat if you ask a question then we will
see you and of course I lost my notes so
I'm Dave door I it's it's a pleasure to
introduce dr. modeski who is an
assistant professor in emergency
medicine at the University of Texas at
Houston who comes to us 22 is our guest
today it's to talk to us about some
informatics heat work he's been doing
actually with Dean siddig as an HR q
fellow very recently and I have some
additional information here so he he
actually was interested this early on e
attended Stanford and he got a degree
related to this I hopefully I'll get
this right symbolic systems with some
some work in HCI right human-computer
interaction work and then he attended
the ohio state university and then end
up doing his emergency medicine so we're
very interested to hear about
topological data analysis about which I
know very little so I I'll turn it over
to dr. modeski alright well thank you so
much for the introduction thank you all
for having me I that is correct i am
going to introduce you to topological
data analysis
which is not necessarily a new field but
it is sort of a field that is emerging
and it's used at least in the Health
Sciences starting out I have no
disclosures or support or conflicts of
interest to declare although that you
may find that interesting because I
basically focus on the outputs of one
specific product by one specific company
the entire time but they are not paying
me and I don't have been a relationship
with them and so basically the quick
agenda the overview is going to be what
is topological data analysis it's a
little bit different than other
statistical techniques and other ways of
approaching data so we're just gonna go
into a brief overview of that and then
mostly what the talk is going to be is a
lot of examples of its use in biological
and clinical applications and then at
the end if there is time and people have
not fallen asleep and they are
interested I can fire up by the ayahs
the IRS platform and we can see some
examples of how you kind of go about
sort of exploring the data of a real
simple data set that I have centered
lying around and at any point if you
have a question of course interrupt me I
generally talk fast and then when I get
nervous and I stand in front of an
audience I talk even faster and so it's
a great way to slow me down and bring me
back to reality as opposed to just
blitzing through an hour's worth of
slides in 20 minutes so so don't don't
feel shy about interrupting me or asking
for clarification if I have gone through
a slide way too quickly because some of
the stuff is a little bit odd so one way
to talk about what topological data
analysis is is to sort of start with
what it is not there is sort of a
substantial overlap with a couple
different areas and other areas of
mathematics but the application differs
just a little bit from each it is not
graph theoretic network topology which
is you know one approach to visualize in
the interconnectedness between
relationships underlying a data set it's
similar to TDA in which the shape of a
network has value at least the
collections of vertices have a specific
relationship their relocation in the
network you encode some representation
some meaning but the graphs and graphs
theories are built and designed to
describe processes and relationships and
they're not really for exploring
interacting with data in exploratory
fashion cluster
ring overlaps some of the principles of
topological data analysis it describes
some methods for grouping similar
members within a data set which is part
of the way that you go you go about
topological data analysis and it uses a
variety of statistical similar
statistical tools but the key difference
between topological analysis and
clustering is that the clustering
methods produce try and produce distinct
unrelated groups whereas topological
analysis is all about findings is
relating groups to each other and as
specifically you can obscure
relationships between different parts of
the data and then topological mapping it
shares the word topological but it has
nothing to do with nothing to do with
topological data analysis but it is a
spatial representation of data but it's
where that but in topological in
topography mapping the sort of the the
specific the coordinate the coordinate
locations in the relative locations to
each other in sort of whatever mapping
plane have us that encodes information
into that whereas in topological
analysis the actual location you show it
in a graph doesn't actually encode any
specific information it's all about the
relationships and the data not the
location like a map or a map back where
the two-dimensional coordinate or the
3-dimensional coordinate system encodes
some sort of information or meaning so
like I said I'm talking fast slow me
down or need to so like I said
topological data analysis it's about
since it's specifically concerned about
building a shape out of the data so that
that the goal is to infer high
dimensional structure from loads from
essentially from a low dimensional
representation by assembling all these
discrete points into a global structure
and these techniques are specifically
designed to evaluate large quantities of
heterogeneous scientific data with the
relationships that don't lend themselves
well to traditional methods of
scientific inquiry like multivariate
linear linear techniques or the
clustering techniques or like like
project legs some of the some of the
other like I ghen values high projection
type methods of that analysis there are
several different techniques and several
different visual visualization tools
there's inflammations for our you can
use those implementations for matlab
their stuff in java and python but what
mostly i'll be showing you is
represented from my oz d's proprietary
tool
it is called iris and for no specific
reason other than it's the most
accessible tool for clinicians to use
and doesn't require any specific
statistical background which is great
because I have never taken us associates
course in my entire life so it's it's
interesting that I am up here talking
about all these different statistical
techniques and trying to explain
interesting graph network bureau and so
and so forth but so what it is it's an
accessible tool for people who are not
necessarily don't have a foundational
experience with with statistics to sort
of get into exploring large datasets but
like it's not at just a single tool or a
single algorithm it's essentially a
framework for visualization of
mathematical outputs it's a combination
of different functions that you overlay
on top of the data that distributes the
different distributes your information
into a sort of a topological space and
finds groupings throughout these common
functions even though it can use you
know use essentially any mathematical
function as your sort of lens or your
filter for process pre processing the
data what seems to work best are
Euclidean functions on regarding the
distribution of data and the centrist
the central pneus of data sets and then
finally topological data analysis it's
kind of geared towards the buzzword the
big buzzword a big data where you have a
massive heterogeneous clinical data or
genomic data that doesn't just that's
just overwhelms traditional approaches
to the sort of analysis I oz D like I
said I don't work for them you'll see
their name up here a lot but they are
and if you haven't heard of them already
you'll probably will be hearing of them
they are the most innovative company in
big data like we're in a fast company
magazine so I just have I have an
academic sort of relationship with them
where they I got they gave me access to
this tool in exchange for i'm not sure
what they got what I got out of it other
than what they got out of it other than
giving me a steel tube I guess I was
supposedly I was supposed to go back and
be a champion for their product and I
guess I've kind of technically worked
because I'm up you're talking about but
uh so the basis of topological data
analysis so nodes is the sort of the
common language of topological that
nozzle nodes are a group of similar
objects or in your data set so this
means from your data
you'll find some measure of similarity
you know some sort of a distance measure
or a variation measure or distance from
the center sort of measure and choose
how many nodes to create and then
whatever software using will essentially
group members into clusters based on
those similarity and this is how it kind
of differentiates from clustering
methods is you can decide how many nodes
a member of your data set can be
included into so that's really the key
that get that generates that that's the
key element of topological data analysis
that generates the associations is that
each member can be a part of more than
one node as opposed to clustering where
you just make it everything is every
element belongs to a single cluster
whereas in topological analysis mostly
that you try and make it so that
different elements from your data set to
belong to more than one node and then
you connect the nodes based on you know
every every node that has a certain
element in it is connected to all the
other nodes that have that element in it
because and those are called edges and
so you end up with nodes connected by
edges and that essentially connects all
the similar things together in a network
of this sort of associative network and
the associative network gent generates a
shape and the concept is that
topological data analysis the shape
encodes the meaning so you have you take
the nodes you put members into the nodes
and then the way it connects and how
they connect to each other and all the
different features of the network when
it makes a shape in space and we'll see
lots and lots of examples of how this
works and hopefully it'll become more
clear than I am describing it will
encode some meaning and then colors when
you see the networks with colors you'll
see that they'll the color you basically
color the map based on the features that
of interest so if you have a data set
with a whole bunch of dimensions and you
want to see the insta where the areas of
them of your network that have the
highest incidence of a certain certain
feature and you color the color of the
network based on that feature whatever
the values that feature is in those
nodes will hype sort of highlight so
using the language that I as it uses the
process starts by choosing what you call
that lens essentially this is a filter
function it's sort of a mathematic
preprocessing the describes the
fundamental fundamental nature of data
point and it's sort of the initial step
in dimension reduction so describing the
relationship of your data point to other
data points in space and like I said
before the sort of the filter functions
that are built into the I Ozzie tool our
measures of local density or measures of
central tendency or and our measures of
variance essentially and then you take
the nodes that you created based on
similarity and then you can see how when
you start connecting the edges you start
generating a shape out of it rather than
just one and it's so its butt and yet so
you connect the nodes and it stretches
out into a shape of sorts based on the
edges and the structure in this instance
by selecting the paste the by connecting
the like elements from each node and
this is sort of another practical
example they put together if you can
imagine the human hand is a
three-dimensional point cloud
represented an original like utility in
space you're original cloud looks like
you see in figure a and you might be
able to imagine a sort of a filter
function that looks at the hand
essentially encodes a little piece of
data for each point based on the
distance from the wrist and so you've
got the points in blue the sort of the
hand in blue is the closest to the wrist
points in red are the farthest from the
list and then if you then if you sort of
create bins on those filter values for
the ones they're similar most similar in
space so each finger had the each point
the finger is most similar to the other
points on that same finger so if you've
been them based on bin them based on
similarity in space and then filter them
based on distance from the hand you can
see sort of it looks like see you can
sort of say based on distance from the
hand you have sort of the six layers
from the distance for the wrist if you
bait and then if you also have a
similarity function running each set of
points in the cloud associate with the
ones in their same finger and
at the bend that kind of combines to
making a set of nodes that actually
turns out to resemble a hand that seemed
to make sense okay great sound smarter
than i expected think I sound so here's
a little bit of a practical example that
kind of brings out the difference
between topological de analysis and the
other approaches this is a 1092
individuals from the thousand genomes
project this data set this is not my
work this is other people's work estatus
it's a 3.6 million single nucleotide
polymorphisms identified in the
sequencing project and this is a
projection that uses principal component
analysis which is sort of a measure the
the variance between the between the
points in space the red dots are the
folks with East Asian ancestry and you
can see that if you make a projection
using PCA you don't really see the East
Asian ancestry folks are scattered
throughout this the projection that they
made but you would expect if you station
ancestry is a common thing in this the
single nucleotide polymorphisms should
be the same throughout East Asian
ancestry so if you're really trying to
do your do we would expect the data set
that the east a the red dots to cluster
more or be more associated in space
which you don't see with us yet with a
pca component analysis if you do a
clustering sort of algorithm on it which
you can kind of see at the top it does a
better job of finding the similarities
between the folks who have East Asian
ancestry based on their SNP pairs but it
still doesn't associate them all with
each other it finds five or six discreet
little clusters of east asian ancestry
which may be intuitively trip to some
extent but they should be at least
connect interconnected in some fashion
so even if there are you know which
there probably are multiple different
types of east asian ancestry which we
obviously know there are and they each
have their own sort of pattern of
single-nucleotide polymorphisms they
should be more like each other in
something and some related to some point
related to each other in some way rather
than just streetly separate it out and
sort of a cluster anything like this
and so what it looks like when you do a
topological projection of this is that
your East Asian ancestry the nodes sort
of the nodes cluster in space they are
all associated with each other in space
and they're in a distinct feature apart
from the rest of the the rest of the
folks and the different single
nucleotide polymorphisms distribute
throughout space so in this one the red
nodes are the nodes that have they have
been together essentially the rows in
this database who have the highest
frequency of east asian ancestry and you
can see essentially it's almost like you
say if you took those clusters from the
previous one previous slide and you
connected those clusters specifically
and then everybody else has connected
the clusters they were most similar to
and most similar to and so on and so
forth and then you have you end up with
the piece that you end up with you end
up with essentially an insight that's
coming from the shape of the network and
then where the pay then we're end and
where the where these nodes end up
falling in your cut your data analysis
Network so one example what you can do
with this group is you can select all
the patients in this group and then
because this is a single nucleus it's a
snip database essentially you can look
and see what what the relative frequency
of the different nucleotides are within
that that group of notes you have and
one of the ones that pops out when you
take a these are all the chromosomes
essentially from 1 through 22 you can
look at and see which snps are most
frequently expressed in that East Asian
ancestry group and the one that comes
out with the highest sort of relative
instance compared to the other ones is
this RS tune whatever it is 299 408
which is associated with the gastric
cancer that's you diffuse type gastric
cancer that's a that has a higher
prevalence in East Asian population so
this is not a novel insight necessarily
because this was not something that was
known before they made these charts but
it's a pair of these graphs but it's an
example of how if you had made this
graph and you have found that East Asian
ancestry and you would run it through
this you would have found this is ana so
this is this is what exploring the data
would have led you to see this
association and then you could have gone
back and then explore this hypothesis
further here's another example
population data this is 313 samples from
individuals regarding gene copy number
variation they've built a network off of
it and filtered it for differences in
gene copy variation and essentially it
naturally separated itself into regions
based on their common ancestry so you
had a most people with gene copy
variations from Africa landed in one
network and European another East Asian
another network and what's interesting
with this you can then color the network
based on specific gene variations seen
most frequently in the African
population and you can find out if you
know this sort of this the singleton
group these are the ones who weren't
similar to anybody else when they did
their first run-through and you can sort
of you can basically it sort of see if
there's you can basically you can you
can almost you can identify the
singletons based on the copy the copy
number variation that's most frequently
seen you can sort of if you're not sure
which of the three ancestry they share
they have most the most in common now
you now you can kind of figure out which
singleton where that singleton is from
and you can see that some people from
Europe have some overlap for the African
ancestry and almost nobody in East Asia
has any overlap with the African
ancestry and then one example of sort of
the shape you can see East Asia the East
Asian ancestry group they used here it's
sort of a flat planner it's just it's a
grid network almost essentially each
each node in the East Asian Network they
all the same copy variation but they're
not that similar to one another they
kind of spread out whereas in the
African network you can see they almost
have a starburst pattern they like us
there's like a single node surrounded by
a little daughter nodes and what happens
it would actually they found out early
noticed when I went in through this data
set and try to figure out why it was
making those different shapes is it
turned out it was all mother-child pairs
so the east days and data set they got
all they were all similar to each other
because they had to say at similar
ancestry but they're all different from
each other the African ancestry it end
up being like they had a couple just a
couple families worth of data basically
and so I had a same number of data
points but they were all they were all
closely related and so it kind of
settled into this star Pat starburst
pattern and so that's one of the ways
you can sort of see that there's a
something is so there's an insight
inside the inside the shape of the data
that's different than just than just
what you would otherwise expect
does anybody have any idea what I guess
trying to see if hat says up there
anyways kind of does then we have an
idea what this might be what network
this is using it right now it's the
human brain so there's a publicly
available data set of protein expression
levels for the human brain that's that
you can download and somebody created a
topological projection of the human
brain it actually kind of looks like the
human brain the cells are different
enough and distributed enough with
different functions and different gene
levels of expression that it ran based
on the filter functions they use and the
way they they way they sort it they may
have tried to make it look like a human
brain because you can make these
networks almost like almost anything but
it kind of looks like the human brain it
even has the brain stem doubt the point
of reference and what they did is they
what it's sort of an example of like I
said this is the this is a protein level
expression for different parts of the
human brain and what the top is on the
left you have the hippocampus is
highlighted in red so those are the
cells that were just labeled as the
hippocampus in the data set and the
short of the part on the right it's
basically the the Salvador it's the
cells expressing the highest levels of
this was called the SW h signaling path
of the cellular warts hippo signaling
pathway which is involved in creating
memories I'm so injured so
coincidentally which is not a novel in
sight but this is an example of how when
you sort of when you start exploring the
data and it's been sort of visualize
these relationships you can see that if
you notice it correctly identifies
essentially the cells that light up as
the hippocampus labels also light up
with the same level that also light up
with the levels of activity that are
associated with the things that we know
go on in the hippocampus and the same
thing with this cerebral cortex so the
cerebral cortex is a highlighted here in
this one and then on the right you sort
of see the levels of the MHC class 1
protein our complex assembly process and
the MHC class 1 complex also has
activity and hippocampus as well as the
rest of cerebral cortex and it's also
that's a cellular thing that's involved
in neuronal plasticity it's also partly
related
and it's also really the you know the
functional remodeling of the brain and
you can see how it's interesting to see
where where in the brain these are
located so these are those are not novel
insights but so in the brainstem same
sort of thing this is a another author
just going through essentially all
different parts of the brain and looking
for associations for highlighting
highlighting gene level activity this is
a cysteine type endopeptidase activity
it's the author wasn't really an i don't
i'm not a neuro neurologist so i don't
know what this clinical significance of
that is because it's a it's a pathway
involved in apoptosis in the and cell
death which seems to have a higher
incidence sort of in that brain stem as
opposed to the rest of the brain and i'm
not sure why the brain stem would have
problems with cell death but the puter
men here this is a sort of the one of
the motor motor centers of the brain
what you see is highlighting here is a
and you know that since then the
peeterman is involved in some of the
neurodegenerative diseases like
Parkinson's disease and one of them on
the right essentially one of the things
that notices is that the the parts of
the brain that are involved with
triglyceride synthesis also light up in
the sections of the brain that are
involved with neurodegenerative diseases
and it's interesting to see if you if
you could it's well known that the
impaired impaired cholesterol synthesis
in these portions of the brain are part
of the disease process that's involved
with Parkinson's and the other movement
disorders so it's introduced introduced
see these wear these things correlates
specifically with their representations
in space even though when you make
something that looks almost
anthropomorphic like the human brain
like but it's not just not novel
insights and life sciences so
essentially Enys and they use this
application in fraud detection and all
sorts of different things essentially
the larger and more complex the data set
the better I don't know if anybody here
is fan of basketball or deal with that
but they somebody made a network out of
all the Division One teams and the NCAA
is a couple years ago if you remember
Duke and you as the year that so Duke
and UNC there in the ACC they're very
similar teams they shoot three-pointers
they run they run rotate
I'm a running game they have a big
three-point shooters on a big man in the
center they end up very same Kentucky's
on that same sort of thing VCU's is the
year they were doing the full court
press trying to steal the ball trying to
really really lots of activity there up
there on the similar side Stanford oh
it's coming by the way it's colored the
red color is the most wins and blue
colors the fewest wins this year that
Stanford was terrible they're not like
any of the good teams essentially so you
see the good teams on the periphery and
then Stanford's in the middle and
there's not any good this year and
that's because they're nothing like any
other teams and but you kind of Butler
so you can see duke unc Kentucky VCU
they're on this they're on their own
feature whereas UConn and Butler are in
their own feature so you kind of Butler
played for the national championship
that year and it was so these are high
scoring teams three-pointers big men
these are defensive focused teams and
they played the lowest scoring
championship game in 60 years so you can
see that you can plug almost any data
set in there and come up with useful
visualisations it might be interesting I
don't know if it's actually feasible or
not to to try and see like to try and
use these networks to look for similar
sort of similar looks like similar play
styles perhaps and if you're trying to
say well as Duke as you and see you
going to win their first round game and
march madness and look for their
opponent in the network and see how unc
is done against similar opponents in the
network and then well there's like that
billion dollar challenge that Warren
Buffett has so if you win a billion
dollars I want some of this it might be
better than picking based on the team
uniform color anyways or seeing which
one your cat liked my wife ought to try
that and so this is another interesting
network so this is another basketball
network and the person who made the
network ended up in the Forbes magazine
30 under 30 for sports between like to
Ron Williams and Kevin Durant he was a
Stanford medical student who essentially
made this network during a summer
internship and you know how like in
traditional basketball there's like five
positions as the point guard shooting
guard center power forward small forward
you know and essentially what he decided
was that
instead of being five main types there
were like 13 types of different
basketball players based on whether they
were you know under the basket and
rebounding all the time or whether they
were you know outside the three-point
line and shooting all the time or
whether they were distributing the ball
or whether they're riding the bench as
they say the role players so you know
you can think about it there's power
forwards in the NBA who are very
different from each other like dirk
nowitzki shoots three-pointers he's out
there all you left by the three-point
line he doesn't bang around then you
have a mari Stottlemeyer LaMarcus
Aldridge a large Aldridge has kind of a
mid-range game whereas all Amar'e
Stoudemire is always under the basket
but they're all definitely power
forwards so just by making essentially
by making this network and publicizing
in some fashion he ended up in forbes 30
out of 30 and it's sort of like the
future of NBA like building a sort of
Moneyball except apply to the NBA by
using sort of similarity features to
describe your because you can you can
use this describe your teams so it's
like this is like the celtics in 2011
you have is actually before Rajon Rondo
was an all-star point guard he was a
role player on the bench they have Nate
Robinson and Kevin I don't know how that
Shaquille O'Neal at one point that
surprised me you know on the team
changed the next year and you could
because you could see how as I maybe as
a general manager in baseball or
basketball or baseball or whatever it is
you can sort of model your team they do
and in the distribution of how patient
players are similar in and maybe get
some sort of insights if you had shown
some sort of a model yeah so I think
they were second or third in the East
these years they're pretty good I was
another sort of example of how different
data things form shapes this is a this
is voting patterns in the United States
Congress 2009 which you'll see in a set
so the Republicans obviously earlier in
red and the Democrats are in blue even
though the marred the little thing is
switched but in 2009 it's really
interesting they're basically the voting
patterns were essentially very similar
through the majority of the Democratic
Party there's a couple little fragments
and a couple Singleton's who don't match
anybody else and then there's you know
to two branches of the Republican Party
who kind of long together in their
minority in 2010 it's totally different
and so I know so Obama was left in 2008
start in 2009 there is some users they
still have a
in Congress I guess the Democrats did
but 2010 I guess that's the midterm
elections right so it's a very different
voting environment for the folks in
Congress and so maybe that's the
difference between like you know
Democrats pushing through policy versus
you know the survival I need to survive
to get some get reelection so maybe
that's what fragmented everything so and
then 2011 you see the replicas are kind
of a controlled it's not an election
year it's a Donna midterm year so
everybody kind of coalesced back I'm not
sure only three years of this data from
this this particular authors little
experiment but it's interesting to see
how it totally fragmented for the
election year and then it kind of starts
to coalesce back there's some extent
even though it's still somewhat
fragmented so it's just really
interesting to see how you can do
different things with different data
sets outside of the life sciences so out
colors our independence the leader of
yellow so I mean it's conditional blue
sort of some blues vote with Republicans
a bunch of times I don't know if that
was like Blue Dog Democrats weather
moderates or maybe they're from certain
states trying to look certain way or
maybe they're voting against Obamacare I
don't know but the other video the
orange ones are independence so they're
often their own little thing going back
to the life sciences sort of as I was
talking about earlier with the brain
networks you can sort of make these sort
of fascinating networks with
specifically large volume complex data
sets and one of the things that's MD
Anderson has recently started doing as
long as a couple other people they're
trying to put in these genomic data sets
to try and look for insights for drug
targets and sort of and that sort of
thing one of the emerging so these are
breast cancer patients from two
different microarray data sets there's
the nki and sort of a geez NK a data set
I think it's from the Dutch and GSC 2034
the NK data set has outcomes of
survivors as death and the gse is no
relapse versus relapse and even though
these are two total two totally
different data sets of different
patients using the same sort of using
the same sort of filter functions on
both datasets you sort of end up with
the same shape in the same distribution
of that of the same associations and
data which is kind of interesting and
it's kind of it's kind of a good way to
sort of verify the internal validity of
the tool if you put two data sets of
patients patients who should be somewhat
similar and you run through the same
filter photo shoot you get outputs that
are somewhat similar and so the same
thing happens
but so what's interesting about this one
so it's a basically it's high ESR which
is the estrogen receptor versus low ESR
and looking at relapse versus survival
in both of these and what's kind of
interesting is you have you know some
are some highlights are that survived in
some high str that didn't do well and
then you have some clusters locusts are
on both sides that that didn't didn't do
well and then over on the other side is
the circus chemokine levels and it's the
kegg key mikhay in which oncologist I
don't know specific significance of that
but essentially the ones essentially in
the patients who have low ESR 1 levels
they all generally had a little bit more
ke g kima crime levels but the one
they're much higher in the survivors
versus the folks who didn't do well so
ESR one- and lower key mikhay levels
with a poorer prognosis and ESR one- and
heike mcklein levels was positive for
the prognosis and so ke g so you could
you could so went into identifying just
this difference in genomics expression
between survival and depth populations
and certain and just the in just a
specific segment of that population
might end up leading to some sort of
insight and sort of how to target
certain a certain a certain part of a
certain subgroup of you know cancers
that didn't respond well to conventional
therapies or explains why a certain
subgroup doesn't respond well to
conventional therapies so even even
though this doesn't necessarily tell you
what to do it could least hypothetically
inform a trial of you know if you saw
somebody who had low ESR 1 levels and
low chemokine levels maybe you wouldn't
start with your typical therapies
because they they already know that
those patients are going to relapse or
die maybe you go straight to your second
or third line there another exploratory
analysis this is also cancer on this is
a map based on RNA expression from two
different types of tumors so it's a
variant cancer on top and breast cancer
on the bottom and you get bits ovarian
cancer on the top and ovarian cancer on
the bottom essentially because those
tumors when you put them all in a
database together they are most alike
that all the varying cancers are most
like each other and the breast cancers
are most like each other but in the
middle are the cancers that are the most
the most genetic material between the
boast both this between each of them and
so if you look at progesterone levels in
this one this is the PGR receptor that's
almost universally on just the ovarian
breast cancers the erbb2 which is the
target of Herceptin that's also almost
universally on breast cancers the
estrogen receptors on both ovarian and
breast cancers but essentially what you
can see is there's a little bit on a
little bit ovarian a little bit of each
each of these different ones highlights
the highlights the edges so it
highlights the ovarian cancers that
hides the breast cancers but this region
in the middle where the Panzers are kind
of overlapping what these turn out to be
is the triple negative breast cancers
they don't express any of these they
don't express progesterone they don't
express estrogen they don't express or
is the protein targeted by Herceptin and
so as turns out that so essentially the
breast cancers that are most like
ovarian cancers are the triple negative
breast cancers and what they do Express
is mostly p53 which anybody who's been
to medical school remembers p53 is the
tumor suppressor gene it's basically
behind its one is one of the major
genetic mutations that's behind a lot of
the cancer cancers we see which is not
surprising looking at just going through
all the different genes this author
found the PSAT one genes there was a
little bit of expression in those triple
negatives and Fox Fox a one not so much
but this PSA one that's expressed in
ovarian cancer and the triple negative
breast cancers that's also common to
that's actually an enzymatic product
that's also expressed in colon cancer
and the theory is well maybe this maybe
this is since the enzymatic process can
be it can be target and it creates a
protein anything that creates a protein
can be a theoretical drug target and so
the authors like well I did this little
exploration and while maybe PSA one
would be a potential drug target for
patients who have triple negative breast
cancer you know that this is you know a
couple you know published mid last year
or something like that so I don't know
if that's actually going to go through
or whether it's going to be informal
clinical trial but that was the author's
ideas like okay well maybe maybe this is
an option so to do now you have I guess
that I've showed you what other people
have done because a lot of their work is
a lot more
finished and pretty I'll talk a little
bit what what I have done and
essentially what I've done has just gone
around and loaded all the different data
sets that I put into it and had access
to this first one is a representation
from our stroke thrombolytics registry
if you know much about stroke and
emergency medicine there's this big push
from American Heart Association to use
the clot-busting drugs TPA and stuff
like that Genentech behind this and the
American Association and so on and so
forth but one of the problems with the
clot-busting drugs is that they also
cause bleeding they cause either the
stroke that wouldn't Jesus they caused
ischaemic stroke to turn into
hemorrhagic strokes and when you cut you
the clot-busting drug it just keeps
bleeding and bleeding and bleeding and
when it bleeds Don stop in your brain
that's a bad thing so initially I was
doing research to see if doing coronary
doing cerebral angiography before giving
the clot-busting was affecting the
activity of the clot-busting medical ins
seeing if the blood-brain barrier was
being damaged by the you know I
automated contrast and seeing if there
be increased intracranial hemorrhage
because we were doing the angiography
beforehand you know and you have to
verify there was a clot before giving
the dangerous medication turned out I
didn't find anything there was no
difference between the two groups in my
little sample but I took that data set
and I threw it in here and this is
colored in stroke severity so
essentially it made this interesting
sort of made a loop essentially out of
stroke severity where the mildest
strokes are all over there and there's
sort of two branches of similarity and
then they merge over here with the most
severe strokes and when I look at
death's the mild stroke sup in the sort
of upper right-hand corner almost none
of them have almost none of them died
but the patients who actually end up
dying are sort of fell into these three
different clusters and if I select the
nodes in those clusters and look at you
know what's different about those three
different clusters of you know deaths
compared to the rest of the background
population it turned into sort of three
really distinct groups at least in our
thousand patients that we had in this
registry you had like the very elderly
who had a bunch of medical problems
before they had their strokes they
didn't have any bleeding in their brain
as a complication of the drug but they
were so sick at baseline and they had
such a bet and they had sort of a
moderate stroke but they were associated
baseline they died within seven days
just because of it though I don't have
to
don't weather like dnr beforehand or
anything like that well that turned into
one specific group of deaths another one
was if they were old but not super old
but they had tremendously profoundly
disabling strokes and the head bleeding
in their brains they also died within
seven days which makes a lot of sense
but within once it's interesting was
actually a young group a group with some
people who are in their 30s in it that
also died and they died because they had
really severe strokes and they had
massive leadings a symptomatic camera
just meant they had a little bit of
bleeding and they got worse that
Franklin hemorrhage after lyrics means
that like its space occupy and slee
these people were clearly harmed by the
medication and what's the theory is you
know their stroke stroke patients are so
different the types of different strokes
are so different the medication has sort
of a marginal safety value but it's
recommended as a blanket statement to
give to everybody so if you do a sort of
retrospective analysis like this and you
find these clusters and profiles of
distinct patients you could in theory
design a future trial where you actually
take these specific groups of patients
and see and competitively to see if they
actually have the prospective evaluate
the risk benefit ratio instead so you
can modify sort of the blanket statement
to exclude groups specifically like this
I mean it's a lot of these patients
they're so profoundly disabled they
might die whether they get the medicine
or not you don't know that huh
these are all scheming strokes none of
these aren't avians Street Navy I'm with
politics there's any trouble but you
should see a navy I'm on the first
non-contrast head CT if so if you start
with bleeding and you that's when you
stop the process altogether so if yous
are all people who have negative scans
initially for bleeding they thought it
was at a steam extra they turned out to
have strokes they had mostly terrible
strokes before and then some of them
died because of this ropes and some of
them died through the complications of
the medication and it'd be nice to
separate out specifically what's built
little sub groups in our population
would do our being and what are harmed
by the medication for his being helped
by the medication and we don't have that
data yet so it's kind of it's this kind
of whose work is where hypotheses start
essentially a hypothesis generation when
you look at these kind of data sets
another application I've been exploring
is I'm sure you can really read this but
this is this is essentially an example
of like what you can put in put directly
into iris to sort of analyze this is
sort of this for our medication safety
data base this is just these are you
know financial numbers alert date time
whether the medication alert was
overridden or not what the nurse said
whether they're going to monitor the
patient or whether it wasn't clinic
significant other and this is from a
database of nurses who are overriding
alerts for high potassium so we have
these handheld barcode scanners I'm sure
you'd probably hop you're off possible
values into you scan the patient you
scan the medication and it looks for
some Fergus there's such as soon as a
port engine behind it looks for book for
problems and this is a specific one that
was looking to see if they were giving a
potassium containing medication to a
patient who had a high potassium level
which is in some states called lethal
injection and it's how they execute
people so of course when we found out
that this alert was being over an eighty
percent of the time by the nurses we're
like so we're lethally injecting all of
our patients great so of course the
medication safety committee was tasked
with figuring out why they were doing
this whether we should just fire all the
nurses or whether there's a problem with
the decision support and of course you
offer I know that it's a problem with
the decision support because you're all
you've all know clinical medicine and
then doctors nurses are generally doing
the right thing and not trying to kill
her patients so what happens is you I
loaded into iris and I highlight it
based
on the alert overrides there's
essentially a cluster and a feature over
there where they all group together for
the most part and if you look what look
at what's what's statistically different
from the cluster to the rest of the
background noise as you find out that
it's people with age of 0 which is
people who are all less than one year of
age in the system it's all the people in
the NICU and it's all the children's
hospital wards so those lip patients
that we're trying to kill so it turns
out that panel nurses are saying it's
not clinically significant whenever
they're overriding it and it turns out
they also in the NICU babies they're
hard to get blood out of so what they do
is their heel sticking them and there's
everybody knows in medicine that the
when you he'll stick somebody it's
traumatic to the blood cells and I
hemolyzed you know they break apart they
release their potassium into the
bloodstream and you have spurious
elevation of potassium so the potassium
levels that they were using for the
alert sort of the alert decision engine
we're all wrong and so they were getting
these all this so they were getting
these alerts the bedside they knew the
potassium level that the alert was based
on was wrong so they're just overriding
it and that's basically where all of our
overrides are there's a couple overrides
you know from the adult populations but
almost all the adults were being
appropriately backed out whenever there
was a hyper k alert it was only in the
NICU only in the children boards so
that's so you can see that you've data
set that's you know it's categorical a
numerical and it's just just it's great
it's it's you know heterogeneous data
but you put into it this sort of this
technique depending on the filter
functions you use can actually make a
shape out of it that gives you some
useful clinical is this is my big
project that I'm trying to work on it's
another example of what I would call me
for a predictive application out of it
so this is a big database of 43,000
children with mild traumatic brain
injuries so it's like you know mostly
well kids who have bought their heads
they fallen out of their cribs we've
been in a car accident but they look ok
for the most part a very tiny percent of
these patients like one or two percent
actually have a serious intracranial
injury but we're trying to somehow get
away with not but the because people are
worried about lawsuits and missing
things they're scanning like seventy
percent of these kids to find the two
percent so that's not good it's a lot of
radiation is a lot
so these folks they did a lady there
there big a big prospective study to
gather a lot of information they did a
recursive partitioning analysis and they
came with a decision rule that basically
catches it's like ninety-nine percent
sensitive but it's only about it's only
right about half the time it's like
fifty percent specific so I ran their
database through it and unfortunately
it's really hard for you to read so I'll
read it for you because formatted and
it's just too wide format for the screen
but basically it kind of falls into five
distinct profiles my theory was or my
hypothesis is that if you can rather
than take those six elements of
recursing partition analysis and make a
sort of blanket statement that gives you
the only classifies half your population
and you don't have any sort you'd have a
a not low risk population that's the
other half that if you take the if you
can group the patients based on sort of
the similarity and associative measures
and then take new patients and then plug
them into the database the data said
essentially and look at where they fall
within you know what their associations
what clusters they would fall into then
you might be able to get sort of spit on
a better predictive sort of decision
support piece of information and so you
can see it's sort of five during
clusters this one is spinal injuries
neurologic deficits and seizures so if
you that was one major cluster of kids
who actually had something bad going on
inside their brain we had kids who came
in multiple episodes of vomiting they
got knocked out and they looked like
their skulls broken you know so either
bruising out of their eyes or blood
coming out their ears I mean maybe that
was obviously before the day before i
made this network vomiting headaches and
just a bruise the pacific location of
bruise on their head and they couldn't
remember the event that was like another
group of patients they sort of all
clustered together all had simplest this
sort of constellation of injuries all
heard together in a sort of a region of
high incidence of team of intracranial
hemorrhage patients who had really bad
headaches and also lost consciousness
they had a little there's a little group
of patients there I probably should have
pulled out that one too I don't have
that one and this one in his patients
who had moderate headaches but had a lot
of other obvious trauma to their head is
Annette and next it was obvious other
external trauma that sort of sort of
mechanism in injuries or contexts to
suggest that there might be something
else bad going inside their head and
they couldn't remember
so so what I did and I honestly help me
with this part is I made another network
to use to sort of make Network
membership predict to try and try and
see if Network membership could be used
to predict you know the ultimate
outcomes because it's really complicated
to do this with like the sort of
heterogeneous network that I had where
there's like a lot of different little
clusters everywhere I sort of used a
couple new filter functions that came
with the network that clusters all the
head injuries into one sort of course in
the network and it's almost none of the
Henry showed up and the other person to
network and so what we did is we use
this group as our sort of group
membership thing and though so i should
mention this is only two-thirds of the
database i use the other the other one
so i use two thirds to make this network
and the other one third is held out as
my test set and so what we did is we
added each individual patient from the
test set to this two-thirds and sought
and recorded where it fell into the
network and it was a positive finding if
it end up in this section and a negative
fine event up in that section and what
happens is it's about ninety-five
percent sensitive about sixty percent
specific based on if you use group
membership to predict ultimate outcome
which is essentially as far as area
under the curve goes that's it's not
this isn't usable in clinical practice
because you're still only ninety five
percent sensitive but as far as the area
under the curve goes it's a identical to
what pecan came up with and that's with
a pretty that's that's not a really good
predictive network just based on your
sort of looking at it like you know it
had a lot of gray and it was you know
one it you saw that I had five
heterogeneous profiles of people so
putting them all in one group means it's
you your charter defeating the purpose
of separating all this heterogeneous
groups out but it's sort of a proven
concept you can use group membership to
predict outcomes
because I didn't use a very like I said
because like I showed you in this
network they're really different from
each other so all the different types of
head injured patients who had
intracranial injury are different from
each other and then if you clump them
all in one feature the network you're
not really separating them teasing out
the different groups yes right so that's
what I'm hoping to find out that's my
that's act that is the active area of
research I am trying to do what I'd like
to do essentially in conceptually I'm
not going to use IR as the IRS to do it
because plugging it in and processing
through this isn't not that mean this is
a proof of concept essentially a proof
that it's heterogeneous and stuff like
that but the concept would be I have a
patient like you're talking about it
comes in neiva they don't have skull
fracture but you said they seized on
scene and they can't remember whether
they can't remember the accident they
might fall here you know and you could
say I'm going to look at all like this
the 200 closest patients in this network
and what was their incidence of severe
head injury and it'll spit out and you
could say well three of those patients
had a head injury or maybe was 12 it was
12 pages out of head injury then you can
go back to your pay your parents and say
you know I've compared this kid to like
you know 500 other kids who had an
injury similar to yours an injury
pattern a seizure and who lost
consciousness and they had a two percent
chance of having something really bad
going on their brain do you want me to
watch them for a few hours do you want
to scan them right now or do you want to
take them home watching yourself so
that's the kind of information I want to
bring to it because that's that's that's
a shared decision-making thing that we
need to be doing in medicine but we
don't have the tools for it you know I
make that I do this thing of it do you
do this every day we do this every day
in medicine we make a whole bunch of
decisions for patients we don't really
we want to be able to involve indecision
we want to share with them the risks and
the benefits and the alternatives but we
don't have good information good
decision support that has that sort of
granular patient-level data so that's
what I'm trying to do this is and this
is my proof of concept that I want this
turn into a sort of my sort of a
decision engine to try and see if it
works yeah
as applied to the meta-analysis that you
know I'm not met analysis studies in
particular like ones that come out where
you have one time see a cochrane review
comes out says hey we support this
treatment and then the next time another
[ __ ] review comes out you know what
never mind we don't support it anymore
what do you mean by applied huh Alex
just so the problem with so
meta-analyses it depends on how they're
doing it the Cochrane reviews usually
just take the outcomes from the studies
and then wait them they are not true
patient level meta-analyses they're not
taking the patient level data and
running them we get where you can make
us some sort of a patient level network
they're really just waiting the outcomes
for different studies they're not
they're not they're not taking the
patient level data and pooling it you
have to have cooperation and buy-in from
all the different trial authors to pool
their data and a lot of times the data
the people aren't gathering the same
individual data points and the same
baseline characteristics so you just
have to as part of your melon
meta-analysis decide you know what the
flaws are which one you're going to
exclude which is your include based on
their methods and which things they
recorded but they both the most men
analysis especially the cochrane review
stuff they're just waiting the outcomes
that you would this wouldn't be
applicable to what they're doing unless
like the future so there's something
called the all trials thing and the Open
Data initiatives in Europe so there's
there's supposed to be the point where
the new drug makers and all the stuff
all the clinical trial data is supposed
to be in this open repository I think
Yale is doing coordinating the group
with in concert with Johnson and Johnson
is partnering with the Yale to start
with there's a group at Yale that's
going to be managing the open data for
at least some part of what's happening
in the US and I'm not sure who's going
to be doing it in Europe but we are
moving towards the point where we're
going to start getting more and more
access to patient level data from
clinical trials and so we can start
looking at the data and looking at you
know looking at the heterogeneity of the
data not just looking at whatever
outcome the clinical trial told us to do
and so I'm hoping that you know in the
future were going to be able to not just
play with it like this but also build it
into the back end of some of our
decision support tools and decide who on
dipika Tran really needs to be on
difficult ran and supposed to you know
based on the renal function and their
risks and everything else is going on
versus you know putting everybody on
difficult ran because you know warfarin
60 years old or seven years old last one
another piece of work in progress since
we're running
I'm one of our one my co co faculty is
working on emergency department
forecasting and sort of flow modeling in
the merchants department looking for
resource utilization and Serge Serge
capability and stuff like that so this
is actually a network i was able to make
out of the length of stay of all the
patients in our emergency department the
last year so anything in red is over six
hours so i'm sure you're cringing
because you know that six hours in
eternity and emergency medicine and
there should be no hospital that's
keeping people in the emergency
department that long when you get into
academic medical centers you run into
all these constraints and consultants
and boarding and all sorts of things so
we have to have a lot of patients over
six hours so we're trying to figure out
first of all who is over six hours and
once we can figure out and model who's
gonna be over six hours then we can sort
of start predicting what sort of
resources we need to mobilize if these
sort of patients before it happens so
it's like I said these are sort of just
in progress work this one is the
patients who got admitted so you can see
we have a lot of patients who are only
us only it doesn't necessarily overlap
specifically the patients who got who
were here for six hours so that's kind
of thought know intuitively the patients
who are admitted they're the ones gonna
be staying as long as they'll be waiting
for their bed upstairs but it turns out
that's actually not that's not the case
anymore we has a lot what happens is a
lot of patients get the same sort of
same amount of care and the same tests
in the emergency department as the
patient's get admitted we have lots of
patients come in and they get a CT or an
ultrasound and that's you know that's
four or five hours and like the say
based on whatever the volume is the
Merse department and and at the end then
there's a decision made and so there's
the admitted patients obviously some get
quick decision so I'm gets lotus
business but we found it that being
admitted the hospital had no real
association with how long you like this
day was which is interesting because and
it's almost because there are other
types of patients their psychiatric
patients waiting for transfer to
psychiatric facilities and there's
patients who wait in the ER but because
the bed is full and so and it doesn't
this also takes into account waiting
room time so some of the patients who
waited for six hours and got discharged
spend a lot of time in the waiting room
as well this is patient to arrive by
ambulance it does have a big overlap
with the patient's you get admitted
which is it makes a little bit of sense
although there are some people who views
the ambulance service as a taxi service
but it some extent that actually that
does
that this fits in intuitively with the
distribution of outpatients arriving by
ambrose vs vs being admitted and the
patients arrive by analyst maybe they're
the sickest they kind of tend to be at
the fringes where the 6-hour you know
the longer like to stay where so maybe
they had more evaluations in the mers
department these are our walk-ins they
probably spent most of their time
waiting in the waiting room and
essentially none of them got admitted a
very very few of them get admitted if
they walked in that was kind of an
interesting insight and then of course
because we are the second oldest
ambulance helicopter service and one the
busiest trauma center the one of two
trauma centers in the nation's
fourth-largest city this is a this our
arrivals by helicopter which is actually
a significant portion of our arrivals
they don't necessarily spend six hours
or more in the emergency fire which is
kind of interesting so they don't wait
in the waiting room which is number one
if you arrive by it if you ride by
ambulance sometimes they will put you
back in the waiting room because if
you're obviously not sick using its tax
service if you drive a helicopter you
will not they have never done that
they've never put you back in the
waiting room after you arrived by
helicopter and that makes sense mostly
it's trauma patients mostly it's and we
have some strokes that we fly in as well
from the rural areas to try and be under
the time windows for stroke but you also
notice that doesn't just overlap the
admitted patients either we actually
have fair number of patients who come in
because the life light is activated
based on the mechanism of injury because
they see this car that's totally mangled
the person is trapped in the car and so
on and so forth so they call the
helicopter the helicopter comes and you
know at the end of the day they get a
splint and some stitches and they go
home so it's actually interesting to see
that our ambulance arrivals don't
necessarily overlap with our admitted
patients and kind of don't actually
spend that six hours because to get
evaluated immediately treated
immediately and then whatever their
disposition ends up being so this is
this guy's like I says work-in-progress
it's just kind of fun to come to put
your data in there to see what happens
and so so yeah like I said we're trying
to explore this data and see what we can
come up and I that just about wraps it
up and I'm pretty sure I've hit up
against my time so you have any
questions or want to see anything else
or just chat with me i can afford
whatever
your button I have two questions the
first question is you mentioned at the
beginning of your talk that the shape of
the output indicates some facts about
this the nature of the data but then I
became concerned when you said in the
brain example that you can make it look
however you want so can you please talk
about what displays how the display can
be changed by the user and then what
kind of checks and balances are built
into the program to preserve the
integrity of that data I don't think
there are any specific checks and
balances built into this program to do
that the so you could select the brain
example even though they were able to
make a two-dimensional projection that
in Euclidean space appeared to be like
the brain you don't necessarily that out
in two-dimensional space in any fashion
and the same things would have still
highlighted and been associated with
each other and they were still
overlapped in the visualization that you
make I think that person tried
specifically to make a projection in
two-dimensional space and or maybe the
or could just be that the network you
know the cells and the cells in the
brain that expressed the same levels of
protein that are connected to other
cells express the same levels of protein
and so on and so forth it I didn't I
don't have access that I don't really
know how they did it maybe it does tend
to break a brain and that's just that's
just the way when you run through
whatever filter it is without any sort
of nefarious your nefarious intervention
the way it connects knows too similar
nodes it ends up actually mimicking the
shape of the brain because that's
actually how the brain is connected to
each other but that's a good that's good
question I don't have a great necessary
mr. that the other question I had is is
there any kind of like systematic way of
interpreting these because it seems like
so abstract in a way that it could be
subject to who's looking at it yeah so
it's essentially it's an exploratory
data analysis looking for sort of
associations to as hypothesis generation
so everything you see in here
the red herrings and it is it
essentially it is operator dependent
it's not like I sure it's not a straight
for statistical analysis that's defined
by a certain statistical significant cut
off it's these things seem to be
associated with each other through this
specific filter of similarity and then
you have to sort of you have to use it
there's a level of expert interpretation
that you said could either be absent or
present depending on who's looking at
the data and you could end up you know
looking at something that's totally
useless or you can look at something
that's actually really interesting and
useful so is it is definitely operator
dependence objector
and so can you explain more about what
type of filter it is and also how
different filters will affect the
results so different so that like this
the data starting what kind of data set
can you feed into the system that what
you ask sure so you can use any data
that you can put in a tab delimited text
file essentially so it can be and it
could be any data type can be you know
decimal numerical ordinal categorical
whatever you want whatever kind of data
type and the software knows that people
are getting putting different kinds of
data type and it does a sort of a
normalization of each different data
type and evaluate each different columns
individually to figure out what kind of
data type it is and whether it needs to
be projected at whether it need to be
normalized or whether how it needs to be
treated sort of in the back end the
filter functions like I said they're
essentially you can use any kind of
mathematical function as your filter the
ones that tend to be most useful are the
same ones that you would use in
clustering measures of local density or
measures of central t or measures of
variance from the mean so measuring how
different measuring how different it is
from either measuring how its you know
how it how closely find it is two things
in local space or measuring how closely
define it is to the center of the data
set those tend to be sort of
mathematical filter functions that tend
to be the most useful because and it
then makes its makes somewhat sense
because that was the ones that are most
useful in clustering like i said i'm not
a statistician and that was not an
adequate answer in time go ahead you
don't really have to answer this
question but do you know the method by
which they determined the distance
between two points because it seems like
you toss a lot of me and magic comes out
curious about like like how they filter
that data or how they decide which
features so they have actually there's
multiple different options to do for
your distance function built into the
system like they they will do you can do
just straight up Euclidean distance you
can you can do a variance normalized
Euclidean sort of
distance there there's a bunch of dip
and there's like a Hamming distance
which is really good for like
categorical ordinal or categorical
dichotomous values so essentially they
have a bunch of different distance
functions you can use built into the
system and they're based on neither
normally they are normalized or not
normalized and to some extent yes you're
depending on what kind of data you put
in there different filter functions will
give you vastly different results and so
maybe more more or less appropriate for
your data I'm just curious like if you
toss all your data in there does does
the system sort of select like okay this
is the feature we should prioritize over
this no so it doesn't do any future
waiting which is kind of interesting
that's kind of where that you have to be
a little bit of an expert and I kind of
wish there was an opposite right now all
you can do is turn features on and off
so turn columns on and off essentially
when you do it run an analysis so you
can either like like in the basketball
thing I was going to show you a
basketball one that I did but you can
like turn off like free throws I don't
really care about free throw attempts
I'm sorry or we could turn off free
throw percentage because it's not as
useful as free throw attempts or
something with that but I wish you could
do some more waiting it doesn't
necessarily doesn't necessarily wait to
different columns back to each other but
they make that matched me to expert
level for what the audience that they
design the tool
all right yeah
just wondering about the edges between
nodes are they is there any relevance to
your analysis or to the actual software
implementation of the number of common
points in both of the nodes is there a
different edge weight depending on
whether I've two nodes have one point in
common or several points in common I
don't know don't know about that I don't
think that there is any special waiting
to the edges although that would be very
interesting to see and so you get
there's a a gain function that lets you
decide how many nodes a point can be a
member of and that's one way to get you
know very if the data looks like it's
kind of sparse and not associated there
you can turn up the gain and turns into
an links it better so you can see some
of the associations a little better but
I don't know if there's any waiting
specifically in the edges or any
information is encoded in the edges
based on the number of patients in you
know if both wound up both nodes have a
bunt like I said a bunch of features in
common whether that edge is weighted and
I could ask
all right now thanks